from this evening I must give the
British people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home it looks like
these Olympics will be postponed
this time it's the London Marathon
Wimbledon is now canceled Downing Street
has just confirmed that the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson has tested
positive for a corona virus upon medical
advice I was tested and that test has
been positive so I'll be self isolating
8950 eight have sadly died an increase
of 980 since yesterday prevention is
better than the cure if we could keep
him away from a ventilator that's got to
be good news don't think I'm so
different and I don't think there's one
rule from the and one rule for other
people so what's your best memory in
lockdown I would say working out in this
it's amazing the opportunity to sit in
my garden and read a book because that
never happens the occasional family
argument over the rotor which my sister
had drawn up so it was a bit like living
in a police state good afternoon good
afternoon good afternoon good afternoon
good afternoon good afternoon and
welcome back to Downing Street for the
daily coronavirus briefing it's been a
bit difficult without any sport at least
footballs back rushing around every day
to just stopping but it would be lovely
to be able to talk to other people
because the children have the
grandchildren
[Applause]
[Applause]